just this whole process of going through
the baby booms history I began to
realize what a nicer society kinder more
decent society we live in today than
society when I was a kid I am Nicholas
booth reason TV and today we're talking
with PJ O'Rourke the great libertarian
humorist his most recent book is the
baby boom how it got that way and it
wasn't my fault and I'll never do it
again
PJ O'Rourke thanks for talking well
you're very welcome
early on you talk about the difference
of the baby boom and other generations
what makes the baby boom different from
other generations is the way everybody
was feeling we could be or do anything
what unifies the baby boom is the way we
talk to everybody into letting us get
away with it so yeah I do laugh at my
own drove somebody has to write right
yeah that's right that's right where did
the feeling that the baby boom could be
anything or do anything come from I buy
a comic
okay yeah okay let's talk about that
because explain that a bit more they
actually do a little research for this
book and one things I found out was an
inflation-adjusted dollars the median
family income for baby boomers was ten
thousand dollars a year more than the
median family income for greatest
generation and this is the generation
that was born
maybe raised in the Depression fought
World War two that's right these are
parents I hope I'm a baby boomer as well
or people's grandparents and you know
they grew up in a pretty grim world they
did and not only were they poorer and of
course faced a number of of impositions
on their freedoms such as such as the
depression and right war when you look
at the GDP per capita for the greatest
generation it goes sharply down after
World War one way up in the 1920s then
sharp even more sharply down and for a
long time during the Great Depression
and then only starts to ramp up as we
begin to rearm that's not the kind of
economic ramp up you want you put those
two things together the simply the fact
that baby boom children had
more money their families have more
money and the stability of that money if
you look at GDP per capita from 1946
really to the Arab oil embargo it's a
steady upward ramp so the greatest
generation suffered both from relative
poverty and from income and security
you're making a crass Marxist argument
here right that a certain economic base
more wealth gives you a certain cultural
superstructure which is you feel like
you can do anything
absent externally right yeah and the the
period when the baby boom grew up was
until the Vietnam War largely absent of
external external ities was it the
parents who were telling their kids you
know that you can be anything or was it
the kids are saying look at me I've got
money in my pocket and I'm five years
old oh no Superman or have we didn't
know that I mean you know you can only
know the conditions that are around you
we had a children have not too much
sense of Futurity and no sense of
history so so we didn't feel that but
our parents our parents were urging us
to really to act out a lot of things
that they themselves felt that they felt
they never got a chance to do whether
was go to college what it was start a
business whether it was playing the
trombone or whatever they're saying you
know you can be anything you want which
in the case of my dad meant I could be
an engineer they're saying you can be
anything you want and we thought wow
drunk stupid stone the message of the
greatest generation to the baby boom got
through all too well did they resent the
fact that people your age you know you
did get to go to college you did get to
do drugs and live a dissolute lifestyle
you did get to have premarital sex
openly and then I mean were they a gas
because I was on immoral or were they
pissed because they you actually did
what they wanted I think they were it
was more pissed than aghast you know
after all they were veterans of the war
and wartime era and come on tell me that
like
guy was gone off to you edema that he
that he spent the last night with his
girlfriend on the one on front work
slang yeah but you're dealing mildly you
talk about you know what unifies the
baby-boom is the way we talked everybody
into letting us get away with it
and so it wasn't a particularly hard
sell or do I know it really wasn't in a
sense I mean society was moving in a
very permissive direction whatever great
Victorian inhibitions between the
Depression and World War two and to a
certain extent the Cold War those things
were already under attack obviously was
a fight enjoyable to fight but was it
worth you know is it is it better to
live in a permissive society than ever
he knows to be determined that's
probably a question it needs to be asked
a hundred years hence there were a
couple of blowbacks
from the permissive society one of which
drugs while you know i'm libertarian I
am theoretically at least in favor of
drug legalization nonetheless to say
that drugs did not have the widespread
drug use didn't have a deleterious
effect on American society would be a
palpable lie that what are the obvious
effects of marijuana did turn out to be
a gateway drug not in the sense that
people who smoke marijuana went on to
era and are crack but a gateway drug in
the sense that once you lower the social
shaming and a social inhibition against
one drug the others do tend to sneak
through the door a society that winks is
smoking marijuana or even applauds it is
probably asking for a little bit of
trouble with abuse of drugs that really
change in shock when you convene your
Haig court of war criminals Cheech and
Chong will be up there well far be it
for me to get a baby you might be at the
dalla no no I be in the docs with them
know so I'm not I'm not blaming them
marijuana's fine with me it's I've got
teenage daughters this is a drug that
makes teenage boys drive slow that's
right yeah maybe it does some a little
brain damage but so this is almost
everything else a teenager well the
chapters where you talk in the baby-boom
about your drug use in college and after
are very funny and very insightful but
you also make a special case that beer
was the drug of choice of the well sure
beer without alcohol beer was always the
fallback you know probably always will
remain alcohol will remain the fallback
drug because it makes you uniquely
stupid while while remaining pretty
mobile right you know there are drugs
that are make it will make you more
stupid than beer but you can't move you
said one of the other great kind of
cultural contributions of the baby-boom
to american kind of pop culture thinking
is that life is like high school this is
kind of a framing device of the book
talked a little bit about that what we
think about when we think about high
school is the way people self organize
and I'm a high a key and I truly believe
in human self organization but I don't
have a perfect faith that that self
organization is always a good thing
maybe that was simply because I was
shoved in my locker oh I'm guessing that
Hayek wasn't exactly the you know
captain of the football team does
everybody his locker a lot too but he
came out of it you know with an
admirable who use that time when he was
trapped in his locker to think he did
instead of pound on the door and uh of
course the thing here is high axe real
point is not that self organization is
is wonderful it's that it's preferable
to being organized by others and course
a basement through high school and we
say that you know if it came to like
dealing with the Mean Girls versus
dealing with the principal pick the Mean
Girls right time you know Co you know
that brings us back to another jury is
out area of the permissive society which
is the breakdown of the traditional
family structure remarkable number of
kids are born out of well
a remarkable number of kids are raised
by a single parent usually a financially
pressed mom and is this a good right
people seem to be surviving this better
than you know somebody in 19th century
would would sign crime you know youth
crime is down school bullying is there
are a lot of yeah just down after being
very up forever along time you know I
mean it's down essentially because I
mean the baby boom had a lot to do with
Jeff crime and we're aging out yeah you
know the youngest baby boomers are 250
yeah II bet it divert now so well is do
you think there's a kind of social
learning curve then in the same way I
say to keep it with beer or or pot that
you know as an individual there's a
learning curve and like how to drink
beer and how not to drown too fast or
too slow we society like that we see
that with crack cocaine which was
panicking the nation for about a decade
or so and its uses way down its uses way
down essentially because the younger
generation of kids watched an older
generation destroy themselves with crack
cocaine now we have an opiate problem
seems to have originated in our
prescription of pain pills and then
which are very expensive even in and
even more so on the black market
which is in turn driven people to heroin
as a cheaper alternative and this is
making red this is happening and Roy is
where I do my live the governor of
Vermont
earlier this year devoted his State of
the State address to how there was a
nearly you know double doubling the
number of heroin deaths and when I
actually looked at the numbers and it
was something like it went from 8 to 14
in the state of Vermont so it's kind of
like is this just one more hey kids
don't do drugs sister no I I don't think
so I mean I think it will have like
crack did a natural cycle the younger
generation will come along and see that
that an older generation of kids have
destroyed their lives with this this is
a huge human price to pay though to wait
these things out not sure there's
anything else to do but still a big
brush towards the end of the book you
say given all the liberties the baby
boom has taken we ought to be
libertarian
we should be adhering to the Clinton
rules that is the rules that the
Clintons exemplified mind your own
business and keep your hands to yourself
Hillary mind your own business but keep
your hands to yourself it's a good line
but then you know let's focus on reasons
a libertarian organization of magazine
you you're been a long adjunct scholar
at Cato an attitude is America more
libertarian now is it about the right we
are certainly more vegetarian on a
social level things like gay marriage
but are we libertarian on I mean we
elected Barack Obama are we libertarian
on the fundamental government issues
which in some ways are more important
than the Socialists I hate to say that
because why why how are the how is the
our economic issues fiscal issues more
important not economic issues but
political issues are because you create
a political situation that is much
harder to modify escape from change and
social situations this again high acts
arguing is that while we may not self
organize well and our people organize
for us it's always a mess and so we're
creating a national political system
upon which everybody is dependent and in
fact liberals and seem to be working
very hard to make sure that everybody
you know old people young people going
to college anybody who has any medical
problems that everybody is dependent
upon the state and this is ultimately
more dangerous than like an individual
state this tendency is being pushed by
baby boomers
yeah not exclusively not exclusively
what is it how does that match up with
kind of a 60s a high 60s it wasn't as
long things that puzzles me although you
would think that after Vietnam War and
after the sort of exuberance of the 60s
that that the baby boom would be
strongly libertarian right in its
political orientation I think there are
two things that have kept that from
being true three really one is that
dependence that has been fostered since
at least the New Deal if not the
progressive movement more than a century
ago another is that at a crucial time in
our political education big federal
government was on the right side of an
extremely important vital question which
was zip codes sustained Island civil
rights civil rights civil rights we'll
talk about that because among
libertarians you but you see
libertarians stepping it all the time of
how you know if the cost of being free
means having a you know large parts of
the country segregated you know that's a
price I'm willing to pay with it's not a
price I'm going to pay right there's a
total isn't so we watch the federal
government battle conservatives and
indeed libertarians I mean Barry
Goldwater famously wrong-footed himself
by supporting states rights not because
he was a racist but because on
constitutional principles and you know
those constitutional principles were
butting up against the really ugly
reality and there are times when you
simply have to to to to make the best of
the situation as it is and so Barry
Goldwater was wrong about that and not
only did it cost him votes but it costs
the whole reputation of the conservative
libertarian movement there was in
Paleolithic conservatism quite a bit of
racism anti-semitism bill buckley you
know basically devoted his life to
trying to get that stuff out of the
conservative movement as until late into
the sixties National Review was still
talking about how segregation was it's
not always a bad thing that's right I
mean even he had you had trouble really
waving goodbye dad he did you know he
managed to get the anti-semitic nuts
right
and Annie and the worst of the ie me
defended McCarthy for a while but I
really realized the guy was not really a
not the who would grab hold of a real
problem but it would be distorted and
perverted yeah people had slow learning
curves on the serve stuff and so we
watched the federal government step in
and do something about this and I think
we were not same time we also watched
the federal government conduct the
Vietnam War and you would think that
would outweigh a woman might outweigh
the other but but one had to do with the
permanent structure of American society
the other had to do with a you know a
military misadventure
plus our parents really saw the New Deal
and Franklin Roosevelt as being heroic
not a relic in a sense that it actually
worked but and here was at least
somebody trying to do something about
about the depression of course he wasn't
doing the right thing
and of course people have long forgotten
most much of the stuff that he did had
been started by her Herbert Hoover
himself a progressive Republican but
nonetheless they came away with a
feeling that the federal government was
a benign they might be personally quite
conservative
they might even vote certainly they
voted for Ike you know rather than
Stevenson but they still had a feeling
of the federal government was beneficent
it's easy to kind of create a heroic
Enterprise of the federal government or
of a communal society where it's like
we're throwing everything we can against
poverty we're throwing everything rights
racism Islamofascism a real problem with
the kind of libertarian point of view
seems to be that it has trouble coming
up with you know we're fighting for
freedom so that we can sell our
artisanal cheese we can sell raw milk
directly to people without bullshitting
around is there a way to craft a kind of
heroic vision of libertarianism that
really gets the the majority of people
pumping in that drug it's tough or it
would have been done by now because
there is a strong streak of America
libertarianism and if libertarianism
were easy to explain and if it weren't
easy to exaggerate
the effects of libertarianism of the you
know people wandering around with
legalized heroin buttons and so on I
think it would have been done already
certainly enough smart people have I'd
like to think you and me included
that's what of us have applied
themselves I mean Charles Murray is many
many very intelligent people have
applied themselves at grain you know to
crafting you know sort of an agenda that
people could grab ahold of but the
problem is of course is that that
libertarian libertarianism isn't
political right in its kind of anti
political Roy it wants to take a lot of
things out of the political arena
it isn't ideological or when it is
ideological when you get a hold of
excessively pure libertarians it can be
a little sure you know when you are
taping this by the way I had Freedom
Fest so we are and so just that's fright
on the front burner
yeah and we're taping this in Las Vegas
which is probably not the best example
of people doing exactly what they want
what you know that is that for you kind
of the core selling proposition of
libertarianism that you that it takes
things out of the political squeezes
politics down because there are places
where we need a consensus and we all
need to be on the same page we need a
government unknown III covered Mogadishu
right well as any time I talk to an
anarchist I said let me let me just take
you a read Moby do you see Anarchy at
work so the essence is really kind of
removing as many things as possible from
an arena of coercion or a forced
consensus to kind of solve for games and
of course this is a practical matter to
when you task the government any
government but you tests aid the federal
government with writing all wrongs
fixing more things
making everything swell for everybody uh
it physically just can't be done how
many millennial children do you have
three repos yeah I mean I've got one
born 97 one born smack on 2001 born 2004
so I just say all calm one of the things
that is great about this book in your
work in general is that it is deeply
rooted in it I don't want to say it's
deeply rooted in history it's just it's
kind of like dipped in history pretty
much intentionally Millennials maybe
it's because of the internet or
something but you feel like they're more
connected to a sweep of history they
seem to be more globalized that they
understand well they're much more
globalized but no actually because what
happens with the Internet is that it
fragments information in the trying to
get information you know to write our
school papers and so on right we would
of course be copying from the world book
our parents of birthday encyclopedia
britannica I was a stay oh yeah you were
copying from the good stuff you know
stuff teachers hadn't even read but on
our way to trying to find out something
you know we ended up finding out a lot
of other things and some I wish I could
remember who this was somebody said
something very wise about the internet
so you do not question the Internet
you'd oppose it and the internet tells
you only what you ask
yeah so if you just type in riots in
Brazil you get the entire history of
rice and Bruce is not what you meant bro
this is like you know Brazil right if
you if you're not careful here you go
Brazil defeats Germany and you find out
the Brazil was an ally of the u.s.
terminal or 2nr in Germany defeats
Brazil it's so you end up with mosaic
information now I think over the time
the kids put these mosaics together but
I don't think the Internet itself lends
itself to sweep of well you mentioned in
the book that you you feel like the baby
boom not only used up all the drugs but
used up all the peculiar all the weird I
forget the exact phraseology talk a
little bit about that and and yet what
do you mean by that well it's just that
that every generation of adolescent kids
has to do something to shock their
parents I mean it's just you know this
is something that's been going on and
for you know it's mentioned by the
Evelyn Romans I was going to say you
know I think Cain and Abel shocked their
parents yeah well yes i KN definitely
yes yes we there is something to the
baby boom having used up all the weird
so that now kids have to like hurt
themselves a bad day on skateboards and
get piercings and face tattoos and so on
and or but you got to kind of love that
right when your kids come home with a
face tattoo you're going to be like you
know what I got to give it to you I
think personally my house is probably
not going to work that way but I in the
abstract I appreciate their uh their
their efforts to set them well then did
we kick free of a certain kind of
historical cycle with the baby boom
where it's you know and you know what's
funny is that the book is you know I
mean it's caustic towards the baby boom
has a lot of fun but in the end you
really do kind of come down on the idea
that now the baby boom is the real
Greatest Generation they're you know I
wouldn't go quite that far but but
you're very appreciative I am yeah and
then they come around I actually started
the book hostile to Riley boom and in
the end came around to the fact that a
lot of the problems the baby boom was
caused or simply demographic and that
you can't blame that on anybody low
birth rate before the view boom came
along low birth rate afterward and now
the baby boom I suspect you agree with
this really owes it to the next
generation to figure out how to get off
the government hit in terms of Social
Security Medicare we are always are not
not paying but it doesn't look like
we're delivering yeah yeah no I that's
one of the things that started me off
hostile to the baby boom but in the end
I just I think I realized you know what
I you know by just this whole process of
going through the baby booms history I
began to realize what a nicer society
kinder more decent society we live in
today than society when I was a kid you
know a year since I've seen a bar fight
you know I don't think my ten-year-old
boy has ever been in a fist fight I
don't think you know there may be a
little scuffle
but I don't think he's ever had that
kind of violent confrontation it was
simply part of the package right when I
was a kid let me talk about a slightly
different cycle of overtime which is of
your journalism courier which is also
covered in depth in the book and is now
great in parallels a lot of things you
more or less got your professional
journalism start working for an
underground weekly when they were still
called underground and of professional
going but I got my start at a magazine
called puddles actual name I'd change oh
okay I've disappointed so but his name
was every bit as bad it was called Harry
and not even H AI R Y H Arry in the
context of the book you call it puddles
yes you write combat was edited combat
which is the great world war ii
underground
real on resistance paper combat was
edited by Albert Camus and jean-paul
Sartre puddles was edited by Harry Bob
and me combat was in constant danger of
being raided by the Gestapo sinking
vicious reprisal puddles was in the
occasional danger of being raided by
Baltimore cops for drugs yes not for
free speech underground newspapers are
all weekly it's kind of started in the
50s but they became one of the defining
media they do since these two were quite
a little bit about what it was like to
work for an alt weekly you know back in
the day great place to get started
because there was no quality control
whatsoever we had to fill up the
newspaper and put it out once a week and
of course it didn't quite get out
wondering because I have not trying to
look back on it I can't remember whether
it would it would whether it would
finally get published when we were out
of marijuana and needed to revise some
more or whether it would not get
published when we got some marijuana be
dispensed up to do anything but at any
rate gave you a chance to do all sorts
of things and
in any sort of grammar that you wanted
and so it was a great training ground in
a way although that the end product was
pretty dreadful you've moved on from
there you know and I'm skipping over
some stuff but to National Lampoon yeah
a National Lampoon was really my first
real job here I mean 7 News National
Lampoon was a massive magazine it was a
cultural touchstone it changed the way
that people felt they could talk about
you know kind of sensitive topics and
you know the ideals and things like that
talk about your experience at national
input how you came to be there and then
what was the essence of it and and did
that demonstrate some great kind of
Boomer juice in America it did I came to
work there because I wanted to be a
writer I'd moved to New York and
basically I hung around the office so
they gave me some sort of job pestering
people you know trying to write in a
Lampoon style it was my first experience
with people who were really well
educated doing kind of the thing that we
were doing with the underground
newspapers but much more apolitical much
more sort of it was National Lampoon was
was there too just all tearing down no
building up
arguably the greatest magazine cover of
all time but you know by this magazine
or that will shoot this dog yeah ads I
mean what I remember is if Ted Kennedy
was driving a Volkswagen he'd be
president by now that's right your own
photo funnies that you'd run it as well
as what was your most scabrous essay
that you wrote or piece that you read
for the probably mine was how to drive
fast on drugs while getting or wing-wang
squeezed and not spill your drink right
yes now a libertarian cry for an art
it's you know Matty Simmons the
publisher in his book about the about
the magazine's history he kind of
identifies you as a turd in the
punchbowl
because of your politics National
Lampoon at its best I mean it's kind of
like the onion or The Daily Show at its
best it takes on all targets equally and
oh yeah we realize everybody down
long before I was in charge we ran a
cover of Sheamus Jaguar a poster with
him getting a pie in the face those are
nothing sacred nothing is sacred issue
do you feel like possibly American humor
or American kyvan of avant culture at
some point it decided instead of being
kind of thoroughgoing and you know
making fun of everybody punk music was
kind of like this was very broad-based
and it's not don't then it you know
there was this rocket to Russia
yeah then there was this moment where it
no it's you know we're going to be we're
going to be avant-garde but we have to
be politically de rigueur in a very
specific way was there something that
caused that or is that a oh no I don't
think it's a misperception what caused
that as show business in fact what
killed off the Lampoon was the movies
essentially in 1978 Animal House came
along
and it resulted in almost everybody who
was involved in the National Lampoon
getting offers for movie or television
or something or that and then of course
what would already been going on was
Saturday Night Live anyway all of a
sudden the talent pools getting sucked
when the Lampoon had started there
really wasn't much way of a way to make
it was the only game in town in terms of
making a living making fun of things all
the sudden it real every do you say that
like you know it's there was only one
I'm kind of like you know it's kind of
great that there was at least one place
yeah big fun oh yeah I mean you could be
yeah go to mad brow it was more for kids
yeah New Yorker had lost its sense of
humor so it's back in the early 50s I
mean and so there really was and so
people who wanted to make fun of things
for a living we're like drawn you know
National Lampoon and then you've moved
to Rolling Stone which is fascinating
because your work there it's like a
master class for journalism and it's the
kind of the later edge of the New
Journalism where yeah you I mean it's
revelry reported in a serious work it's
funny it's totally readable how did you
how did you go from kind of you know
writing stories about getting your wing
Wang's
used with that spelling it drop to you
know going to Mogadishu and going on
raids with the the guardian angels and
things like that 1980 Doug Kenney died
and he was the guy who basically brought
me in to the National Lampoon he was my
best friend there but the other thing
was that he was and it's funny to say it
now but it sounded old at the time he
was 33 mm-hmm and I was a year younger
than Doug and so I was 32 and I thought
you know this making fun of everything
is a lot of fun and I do enjoy but it's
kind of a kids game you know I mean it's
kind of standing outside in flower
garden peeking in the dining-room window
making faces at the grown-ups and isn't
maybe a time to have a place at the
grown-up table you know so I said do I
want to keep doing this for rest of my
life and I so I and I I tried some movie
stuff and I just didn't like the world I
had I had a good time it paid well I
worked on Rodney Dangerfield's first
feature movie easy money but I just
didn't like the world I didn't like the
world I didn't like the sort of
oppressively collaborative anyway so out
of the blue Michael Kinsley who was done
editor of Harper's asked me to go to
Russia USSR with a group of of leftist
it was a cruise sponsored by the nation
and he thought it would be very funny
for me Michael and I knew each other a
little bit and he knew of my politics or
and he thought would be pretty funny to
send a Republican along hope to find
rolling stone in that period but also
kind of what it meant to be a new
journalist somebody who was interested
in telling stories using fictional
devices being present it's always fun to
be in on the beginning of things but it
was fun to be on the tag end of the New
Journalism because I could learn from
its errors I would use I used fictional
devices but I never used fiction right I
mean I kept strictly to the rules of
reporting while
putting some life and like not denying
my own role as an observer the
Heisenberg principle that you know by
observing anything you change it it
could allow for all that and we not have
to do a peak style copy but you know new
journalism had been around long enough
that I you know could you know as you're
developing as a writer who were the who
were your models or did you have such I
don't know if I really did but I would
say that Tom Wolfe and Hunter Thompson
of course impressed me what I was
finding interesting we have wolf is that
the story is never about him it's always
he's no he's yeah and then Thompson I
think it's all about it yeah and yours
actually threads that needle pretty
neatly yeah because you're there and
you're an interesting character but it's
not just but it's not at all about yeah
it's serious but now among other places
you write for The Daily Beast daily I
guess one of the things I mean that's
interesting is just looking at the span
of this you start with in all weekly and
now you're at a weekly yeah that is only
online um do you feel like over the past
40 years or so I mean journalism has
changed is it getting better is media
getting better or worse you hear people
constantly talking about you know
there's no good writing anymore the
economic space is not there etc I mean
are you optimistic about print are you
optimistic about media or these totally
different beasts now I just don't know
you know I'm just glad I'm not starting
out now because the the model that I
understood the magazine business
basically and pumpkin a book publishing
offshoot of that it's just so different
now
and I think it is harder to make a
living it was always hard to make a
living and you know in this it never
paid an awful lot but now it pays less
they're probably more outlets but it
pays less per you know your your
surprice per word is but look it was
never lavish I mean playboy used to be
famous for paying a dollar award
you know and you know newspaper
editorial sections still poetry no for
not that in the business model is
strange I think it'll sort itself out in
time but the internet started by
amateurs you know it's never really
quite figured out a business model I'm
hoping that they'll get around to doing
it it's probably easier to get published
today but harder to make a living at it
does the shift in media cause people to
have shorter attention spans yes I think
so you know I think it would be hard for
something like Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas to blow the public away today the
way that it did at the time so close
that you know in the baby boom you talk
about how you know that and I don't know
if I have the exact phrasing but it's
that the baby boom didn't invent
[ __ ] but yeah I became expert in it
yes and you also you talk about words
are the pheromones of the baby boom
generation very good at talking it has
the baby boom passed that on to the rest
of the world and I think so it seems
that what yeah yeah we certainly are a
chatty and communicative society and and
as you said a nicer one or a kinder one
it I think so we're certainly more more
tolerant in fact tolerance isn't even a
good word anymore because tolerance
means well I'll put up with you if I
have to you know it is more enthusiastic
about people's differences you know
plotting them embracing them as it works
and that's that's good
the author is PJ O'Rourke his latest
book is the baby boom how it got that
way and it wasn't my fault and I'll
never do it again
PJ thanks for talking to reason well
thank you for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie